League of Legends brand new game mode is
out now and it might be the best one
they've ever made it's fast it's fun
it's Furious and frankly insane at times
but there is a danger here this game
mode is so fun that it might have the
potential to genuinely hurt League of
Legends why well here's why
so for those who don't know this new
game mode is called Soul fighter it's an
arena style 2v2 V2 V2 game mode which
sees four teams of two players pitted
against each other in rotating combat
rounds in a series of new custom maps
it's messy it's chaotic it gets the
heart pumping and games are won or Lost
based on who can navigate each map's
unique obstacles or grab themselves some
healing fruit now that in itself is a
pretty cool concept but it's honestly
just the tip of the iceberg after some
rounds players are given the option to
choose an augment from a random
selection which greatly enhances their
Champion sometimes in truly insane ways
wait for my two days okay you can go you
can go
wait I'm dead but you have three boys
look at the boys go
the game mode came out yesterday for the
wider public but a lot of content
creators have been enjoying it on the
test server for a few weeks now even
those who are Perma tilted
[Music]
now I'm not here to give you a guide to
the game or tell you how fun it is I'm
sure you can try it out for yourself I'm
here to explain to you just how this
might genuinely hurt League of Legends
so game modes in general are nothing new
to League of Legends there have been 18
of them before this one many of you will
have had the chance to play the likes of
Nexus Blitz or perhaps battle the Doom
bots I also have very fond memories of
Odyssey anyone remember that one I think
I absolutely no liked it every day it
was out the ultra Rapid Fire game mode
was released as an April Fool's joke way
back in 2014 but proves so popular it's
made numerous returns since the mode
famously allows players to spam their
abilities on extremely low cooldowns
resulting in explosively fast-paced
gameplay that feels a world away from
the average League game and this is
where the problem lies a lot of players
found the game so incredibly addictive
and fantastic that when Riot finally
removed it they simply stopped playing
League altogether people hated going
from Relentless exhilarating combat that
made them feel like Gods to just plain
old vanilla league and it's not because
there was anything inherently wrong with
the pacing of league but it was like
asking people who'd have a taste of
double whipped cream caramel ice cream
sundae to be okay with just an Apple for
dessert and I'm not just speculating
here Riot have actually said this
not the whole you know ice cream sundae
Apple thing but the rest of it in a 2017
q a former Riot designer ghost crawler
said in no uncertain terms that the
reason Wright have chosen to only bring
back earth once every few years is that
earth makes some people stop playing
League he said that when Earth mode is
activated they'd see huge spikes of
games being played but that after they
removed it numbers would drop down to
levels lower than they were before they
ran Earth he shared some more details
including the fact that after they got
rid of Earth in N A they would see over
twice as many long-time players leave
the game compared to normal raids the
thing is game modes like Earth give you
constant dopamine hits even if you're
losing getting beaten by another team
doesn't hurt quite as bad if you're
basically in god mode while it happens
so the result of all of this is that
Riot has tried to drip feed these game
modes they don't come out too often or
for too long but Soul fighter this new
game mode this feels different Riot have
really gone all all out on this one the
last few weeks we've seen Riot pumping
out content to hike this game mode up
we've seen event teasers trailers More
Trailers more event trailers and
yesterday there was even a full-blown
cinematic for it this isn't just
tweaking the numbers of a few Champions
and letting them be fired out of a
cannon there has clearly been a lot of
work put into this there's even a ranked
ladder A ranked ladder for a custom game
mode I'm currently wood which is the
lowest division you can possibly be in
but the point is this game mode feels
different Riot have been pretty firm in
the past about game modes being
temporary but the reasons we discussed
earlier but on Reddit Riot Cadmus did
say they're not ruling out Soul fighter
becoming a permanent game mode if the
feedback is good enough so the point is
a game mode like Soul fighter may be so
fun that players may not want to go back
to normal League this amazing book
currently temporary game mode will be
around until Riot remove it from the
public servers on sept November 4th at
which point they will have a lot of
decision making to do if they decide to
let it return as a permanent game mode
then great I think there will probably
be a die-hard community built around it
but if they do keep it as a temporary
rotating game mode well let's just hope
not too many players get so hooked that
they end up leaving the game altogether
when it does get removed
I'm not gonna lie I'm kind of curious to
see how high I can climb on the rank
ladder I have to get out of wood I've
only been playing it for a day and I
know I have to get out of wood